he's searching for bodies it's boiling
hot and were deep in the catacombs of
the University of El Salvador
he's excavating the tunnels by hand inch
by inch searching for evidence and clues
to where the dead lay hidden his name is
Israel t Kass and he's a body hunter in
El Salvador
there are many bodies to find so far he
has recovered over 750 killed by the
crime gangs that terrorized the
so-called northern triangle of Central
America at this point he's trying to
find the cavity where the bodies have
been buried and then covered up in the
rubble he retrieves a nail he thinks
could have been in a box or a coffin a
witness to the murders committed in the
country's civil war in the 80s admits
they buried people here this is an
historical crime but modern-day crimes
are his real work and his life's calling
with a continuous army and police guard
he scours the hills around the country's
capital San Salvador I didn't throw no
single purpose yeah you know mujer a cop
the gangs dispose of their victims out
here this is the killing field of the
ms-13 gang 31 people have been executed
here he's found 21 the murders were all
brutal and the woman how was she killed
she had a car I could could he could be
the hair it could be the farm all or
body or body or body it could so the
whole body was cut today yes yes yes and
when she came here she was alive she
died yes yes yes yes alive he's alive in
here killer here but the witness says
that a hour and 15 person 50 answers in
here and only one victim only a
self-taught forensics investigator he
has invented his own techniques he was
also something of an earth whisperer who
can read where evil was done how how
here in for year for year for year I see
or have a change for D for me Ryan
so what do you what you want to do is to
you see the different terrain yeah and
then you can say where the body when it
was buried everybody year every juror
changed the the topography I say so yeah
every year so if this is now today 2020
this is 2015 yeah and this is 2010 I see
so you can say and the body is here it's
24 this is important the the the real
really the the ER the gangs want teeka's
dead he knows this they've tried but he
is a driven man me missing my son or
might whether III I can either I did but
the other person not think how me and I
say III ion and then I hundred the you
you don't know you paying a hundred did
you pain fear you because no not is a
see loss of family yeah and for but this
is some that is I don't know how to say
how do you say that the feel in my in my
in my here yeah because I am a human
such as the scale of the violence here
the body hunter of Sam Salvador will
never finish his work but he won't ever
give up on the victims I am he says the
lawyer for the dead mr. Ramsey Sky News
El Salvador